it's not one thing it was many things
but i did not like
that he'd had meetings with jeffrey
epstein he was
evil personified i had nightmares about
it afterwards melinda french gates opens
up following her and bill's divorce and
the role jeffrey epstein played in their
split the power couple revealed last
year that they ended their 27-year
marriage any of the questions
remaining about what bill's relationship
there was those are for bill to answer
that's melinda sitting down with cbs
morning's gail king on thursday her
first wide-ranging interview since the
split announcement in may
divorce is a painful process even when
it's what both parties want it still is
a very
painful personal decision it wasn't one
moment or one specific thing that
happened there just came a point in time
where there was enough there that i
realized it just wasn't healthy and i
couldn't trust what we had among those
contributing factors bill's connection
to convicted sex offender jeffrey
epstein the disgraced financier died in
jail in 2019 while awaiting trial for
sex trafficking charges
you know it was also widely reported
that bill had a friendship or business
or some kind of contact with jeffrey
epstein it's not one thing it was many
things but i did not like
that he'd had meetings with jeffrey
epstein now
and you made that clear to him
i made that clear to them melinda admits
she met epstein and doesn't mince words
about her first impression i wanted to
see who this man was and
i regretted it from the second i stepped
in the door he was abhorrent
he was
evil personified i had nightmares about
it afterwards my god i feel terrible for
those young women was awful in a
statement to cbs news bill calls meeting
with epstein quote a mistake that i
regret deeply he adds it was a
substantial error in judgment any of the
questions remaining about what bill's
relationship there was those are for
bill to answer okay but i made it very
clear how i felt about him
melinda and bill's divorce was finalized
in august of last year first of all i
think you know i want to say that on the
day i got married i never thought i
would end up being divorced and
you know unfortunately i felt like i i
needed to take a different path but i
probably i didn't have any sense of how
big of news it would be you never you
can't anticipate something like that the
couple shares three children together
and both remain involved with the bill
and melinda gates foundation
definitely a very sad milestone in his
first interview following the divorce in
august bill explained the split wouldn't
affect their dedication towards giving
back you know melinda's a great person
and
that partnership that we had coming to
an end is a source of great personal
sadness
we are
communicating and working at the
foundation and so that partnership we're
going to try and continue
[Music]